-After Special Counsel
Robert Mueller
delivered his report,
President Trump decided
to pick fights over healthcare
and the Special Olympics.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's been a little over a week
since Trump's Attorney General
William Barr released his letter
on Mueller's report,
stating that the investigation
did not establish that members
of the Trump campaign
conspired or coordinated
with the Russian government
in its election-interference
activities.
And, obviously,
that was good news for Trump.
I'd say he's had
a pep in his step ever since,
but he doesn't really
take steps.
[ Laughter ]
If he had a Fitbit,
the only thing his Fitbit
would ever display is, "You up?"
[ Laughter ]
Now, when Barr released
this memo, everyone just assumed
it was a summary
of Mueller's full report,
a word Trump's aides
and the media
have used over and over again.
-The Attorney General's summary
of the Mueller report is out.
-We received a 4-page summary
of the Mueller report.
-This was a summary
of the Robert Mueller report.
-Preview.
-You have the Barr summary.
-The 4-page summary
by Attorney General Barr.
-There you go -- this was
a summary of Mueller's report.
Barr told us everything
we need to know,
and we can all move on.
Got it.
-The Attorney General tonight
sent this letter
announcing
that everybody misinterpreted
what he said last weekend
in that letter.
What he did last week
is being talked about
in a way that he didn't expect.
That's not at all what he meant,
and we should all know better.
"I am aware
of some media reports
and other public statements
mischaracterizing
my March 24th
supplemental notification
as a summary of
the special counsel's
investigation and report.
My March 24th letter was not
and did not purport to be
an exhaustive recounting
of the special counsel's
investigation or report.
-Wait. So it wasn't
supposed to be a summary?
That's kind of an important
detail to leave out.
That's like reading the line,
"The Prince and Princess
lived happily ever after,"
in a fairy tale,
and then you turn the page
and there's a note saying,
"That was not and should not
be mischaracterized
as the ending.
They got divorced the next day."
Now, there is no --
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
To be clear, there's no reason
to expect that Barr's memo
is distorting Mueller's report.
But even if his initial memo
was accurate
and made in good faith,
it's still difficult for anyone
to summarize something
as long as Mueller's report.
For one thing,
the report is apparently
more than 300 pages long,
went well beyond the kind of
bare-bones summary required
by the Justice Department,
and detailed
his conclusions at length.
And you can't boil a 300-page
document down to 4 pages.
It's like when you try
to cram for a test
by reading the Cliff Notes
for "The Great Gatsby"
and you end up writing,
"Wealthy man enjoys
consequence-free summer
in the Hamptons."
[ Laughter and applause ]
So, we have no idea --
no idea -- what's in the report.
Barr says it'll be released
sometime this month,
and yet some Republicans
are already threatening to block
the release of a report they say
exonerates the President.
Last week, Senate Majority
Leader Mitch McConnell objected
to a resolution calling for
the report to be made public,
and Senator Rand Paul said
he would oppose
releasing the report
until there's an investigation
of the Obama administration.
-We need to have information
on Obama White House officials,
Comey, Brennan, Clapper.
That should be part of it.
So, Democrats want
the complete Mueller report.
I'm going to object
until we get a complete report
of all the Obama-era officials
that got this thing started.
-You want an investigation
of the Obama administration?
You investigated him for eight
years and came up with nothing.
The worst scandal you dug up
was the fact
that he wore a tan suit once.
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Where did he get the suit?
How much did he pay
for the suit?"
So, Mueller's report
did not establish
that the Trump campaign
conspired with Russia.
But still, even if you put aside
the question
of Russian collusion,
Mueller's investigation
has still exposed a whole world
of normalized corruption
by some of the wealthiest
and most powerful people
in the country
that was just accepted
in Washington until now.
Just look at Paul Manafort.
The guy spent years
as an unregistered
foreign agent,
lobbying for some of
the worst people in the world.
And in the process, he stole
tens of millions of dollars
from the American people,
money he used to buy everything
from antique rugs
to expensive cars to --
and this is real -- a $15,000
jacket made from an ostrich,
which is why
Manafort's heart dropped
when he walked into
the courtroom and saw the judge.
[ Laughter and applause ]
It shouldn't...
It shouldn't take
a special counsel
for us to find out that some of
the most powerful people
in the country
are hoarding their wealth
by committing serial fraud
and illegally stashing their
money in offshore tax havens.
Even if nothing else came out
of the Russia investigation,
people are learning how wealth
and power operate in America.
I mean, this guy right here
was the President's
campaign chairman.
The only way it could be worse
is if Trump made Lori Loughlin
his Secretary of Education.
[ Laughter ]
And I, of course --
I, of course am just kidding.
Betsy DeVos is still worse.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, at least...
[ Cheers and applause ]
At least Lori Loughlin's
trying to make it easier
for people to get into college.
[ Laughter ]
In fact, even as Trump
and his inner circle
has spent their time in power
enriching themselves,
they've also been trying
to take healthcare away
from millions of people.
Last week,
the Trump administration
said the entire
Affordable Care Act
should be repealed, and yet,
as if that wasn't enough,
the Trump administration
also decided
to pick
a totally unnecessary fight
with basically everybody
by proposing to cut funding
for the Special Olympics.
-Education Secretary Betsy DeVos
came under fire
on Capitol Hill Tuesday
while defending
proposed funding cuts
for the Special Olympic.
The Trump administration
wants to cut all $18 million
in federal money
for the program.
-How awful do you have to be
to try to cut funding
for the Special Olympics?
You might as well
use the money you saved
to bulldoze an orphanage.
"We all know
those orphanages are eyesores.
We're knocking down them."
[ Laughter ]
And the administration's
response to the news
was also proof that
the President has no idea
what his own government
is doing.
First,
Education Secretary Betsy DeVos
said it wasn't her idea
to make the cut
and blasted Democrats
for making a political issue
out of it
during a budget hearing.
-As I said then
and I'll say again,
this week,
had to make tough choices
and decisions
around the budget priorities.
I love Special Olympics myself.
I have given a portion of my
salary to Special Olympics.
I hope all of this debate
encourages lots of
private contributions
to Special Olympics.
So let's not use
disabled children
in a twisted way
for your political narrative.
That is just disgusting,
and it's shameful.
-You guys are the ones
who proposed the cut!
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
If you set --
If you set
your neighbor's house on fire,
and they call 911,
you can't turn around and say,
"Aren't you the town gossip!"
[ Laughter ]
Also, can we go back to this?
-I have given a portion of my
salary to Special Olympics.
-You're a billionaire.
The Special Olympics cut
was $18 million.
Betsy DeVos has,
according to "Newsweek,"
10 boats, 2 helicopters,
and a yacht scheduler.
She has so many yachts,
she has a yacht scheduler.
[ Laughter ]
What's a yacht scheduler?!
[ Laughter and applause ]
Is it someone who --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Is a yacht scheduler
someone who, when you say,
"Bring the yacht around,"
says, "I wouldn't do that.
It might crash
into the other yacht"?
[ Laughter ]
Then, after the hearing,
reporters tried to get answers
from DeVos as she waited
for an elevator,
and she responded by pretending
not to hear them.
-Madam Secretary,
do you any response
to the Democrats' criticism
of your budget proposal?
Madam Secretary, you said today
that you were not the person
that proposed
this funding change.
Can you explain who
in your administration did?
Madam Secretary,
have you spoken to the President
about this at all?
If there's some
misunderstanding,
Madam Secretary, this is your
opportunity to explain it to us.
-I mean, look at her.
That's the face
of someone thinking to herself,
"Where's my elevator scheduler?"
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
-Also, I love how the camera
zooms in on her face.
CNN apparently got the same
director who did "The Office."
[ Laughter ]
-Then after
his Education Secretary
went to Capitol Hill
to defend a budget cut
that basically everyone hated,
Trump just waltzed up
to reporters
on the White House lawn
and told them, "Never mind.
We're funding
the Special Olympics after all."
-Why cut money to the
Special Olympics?
Why would you cut funding
for that?
-The Special Olympics
will be funded.
I just told my people I want
to fund the Special Olympics.
And I just authorized a funding
of the Special Olympics.
I've been
to the Special Olympics.
I think it's incredible.
And I just authorized a funding.
I heard about it this morning.
-What do you mean you heard
about it this morning?
You're the president.
It's your budget.
Who's running this place?
I don't want to be this guy,
but can you go get your manager?
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
And then, on Friday,
Trump just kept lying
about the Special Olympics
fiasco.
During a Q&A with reporters
at his resort in Palm Beach,
Trump was asked
about his decision
to overrule sanctions
on North Korea
that his own administration
wanted to implement,
and he compared the situation
to the Special Olympics
by once again lying about it.
-I just decided
that I would not let it happen.
In a certain way,
it's like the Special Olympics.
For many years,
it hasn't been approved,
and then, at some point, it gets
negotiated out in Congress.
Well, I went out, and I said,
"We're gonna have funding
for the Special Olympics.
-You didn't save it!
You're the one
who proposed the cut!
Where is your manager?!
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
Trump lies like this...
[ Cheers and applause
continues ]
He lies like this
about everything.
In fact, this isn't even
the only budget item
Trump has lied about this week.
Just take something as innocuous
as The Great Lakes
Restoration Initiative,
which was first implemented
by Obama in 2010.
Trump requested no funding
at all for this initiative
in his 2018 budget request,
effectively eliminating
the program.
His latest budget proposes
a 90% cut to the program.
And yet at a rally
in Michigan last week,
Trump told his supporters
he was totally committed
to funding the program
while also making clear
he knows absolutely nothing
about the Great Lakes.
-I support the Great Lakes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Always have.
They're beautiful.
They're big, very deep.
Record deepness, right?
-I am -- I'm sorry, but I have
a hard time believing
you have always supported
the Great Lakes.
[ Laughter ]
You grew up in Queens and worked
in Manhattan real estate.
"As a little boy,
I loved two things --
giant gold buildings
and the lakes in the Midwest."
[ Laughter ]
"I know them all --
Huron, Michelen, Eric,
Titicaca, and Inferior."
[ Laughter and applause ]
You...
[ Cheers and applause
continues ]
When it comes to lakes,
you're out of your depth,
or should I say,
you're out of your...
-Deepness.
[ Laughter ]
-Trump did the same thing
while rambling about wind energy
at the same rally.
He bragged
about energy production
under his administration,
and for some reason,
he decided to go
on an extended rant
about how much he knows
about wind.
-If Hillary got in,
you wouldn't have that stat,
I can tell you right now.
You'd be doing wind, windmills.
Weeend!
[ Laughter ]
-If there's one thing
we've learned
about Trump's presidency so far,
it's that he loves
doing random sound effects.
-Weeend!
Shoom!
Whuh-huh-huh.
Bink.
[ Laughter ]
-That's the whole presidency
right there.
He lies about funding
for the Special Olympics
and tries to take away
his voters' healthcare,
but they love his sound effects.
We're living through
the "Police Academy" presidency.
[ Warbling, imitated gunfire,
trilling ]
Mueller's report may not have
established Russian collusion,
but it exposed
a whole world of corruption
most people didn't know about.
Donald Trump isn't working
for another country.
He's working for himself.
He's enriching himself
while trying
to take healthcare
away from millions.
In other words, we're in deep.
-Record deepness.
-This has been
"A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]